we're going to have a look at cubic
equations intermediate cubic equations
are what happens when this thing over
here is cubed instead of squares but
before we get there I want you to
remember this because this connection I
want to make for you 4x squared equals
81 there's more than one solution to
this in a bed right we all be a solution
to X square equal anyone if obviously
she is last month
okay very good we got the answer
straight away but the obvious edge with
my but there is a plus or minus there's
actually two solutions can you remind me
why there are two solutions what why are
they to sit down yeah very good the top
hold that thought while I let you push
this is so important watching right
there with me why two solutions not
because there is because if you look
back at the original equation right nine
squared equals 81 negative 9 squared is
81 as well right so being that there are
two numbers you can put into this
equation because they both work then
sort of the Blues are solutions that's
why there are two okay if there were
like 15 numbers you could put into here
that would all work there be 15
solutions okay so it's just because I
can find more numbers than satisfied
when you come back to this question
which we did earlier right this question
has one solution because it's only a
single double you can put in here that
works but this one had two solutions
because you can put other these and they
would both equal to zero once you guys
like that make for now therefore
consider
I thought ago this will go with just so
here's another equation and I'll try and
work out coming numbers are there so I
can put it to us that would solve now
that obvious choice is just like you
took the square root of 81 to get
tonight take the square root of 81 to
get to know you can take the cube root
of 27 to get to the other and the cube
root is 3
before the way back down I'd like is to
actually write down that operation okay
- I didn't do the math on the words
actually inverse to undo this cube I'm
going to take the cube root take like
that now your calculator has a cube root
button on it in fact I would show that
you want my calculator I just gave them
both away oh it's a right of the square
root by the earth very yellow if you
went shift square roots he'd get the
cube root button okay and then you can
turn up put 2700 there and you will get
3 we said plus minus 90 are right now
many people their conclusion is all when
you solve an equation like this there's
a plus or minus
why is that and the injuries because
right but I try to get across the it's
not because there's a real reason the
people who only say because when they
look at this they'll put a plus minus
here or as well now this doesn't work
can you help me say why why has one
solution and only one Jake what are you
hopeful insulin right here an algorithm
so here's the top one if you do a
negative times negative is a positive
when you got three negative
name is positive negative negative so if
we try negative 3 and we cubed right
what cuting means as right as it was you
take that number and then you multiply
it by itself that many times right but
you can see and it's actually very
similar to the lock-up problem the
riddle remember right Irena I'm gonna
come back to that point a second on how
many days I got it three is it odd
number it is odd number for me to pair
up Halloween but this all gonna pair up
so that's why you get that don't agree
with me okay so please no please don't
you can see when you're solving cubics
equation oh this will be very simple how
many solutions to get you don't get one
by this doing a bunch of Mines
you just get the fun one
okay so I've been asked and on this good
do something love them if you had
already open up your laptop sedimentary
do it now and you do have to do it
quietly so you can listen to what are
them say Jacob you too
the question was what does that need to
leave your arms for eating bad for let
me show you okay well I chose X cubes
example X cubed equals 27 because 27 is
a cubic
gives you a nice DW now very easily
change that I can ask you to solve this
30 is not a cubic number and a lot of
people will look at that number 10
because they're like I can divide by 3
now when you're going to calculator I'd
like you to do this if you punch in the
cube root of 30 the cube root of 30 then
you get this disastrous decimal
expansion in fact I'd like you to tell
me what this what is when you press
equals what you get 3 right 1 2 3 5 0
did I get the right digits gonna be okay
yeah now I want to point out two things
number one share it up the decimals they
go on forever and they never repeat it's
irrational right so if you're never
going to get the same triangle or
doesn't particularly and you notice it's
a just a bit R 3 it should be just a bit
up 3 right because birdie is just a bit
of odd 27 ok now please note what you've
got here and you can label it as such
this ke the cube root of 30 is exact
there's no approximation right this is
precisely what it is it's a way of
describing it whereas this is an
approximation which this chooses one or
a decibel approximately does a certain
order it right
it's just coarser so you can see three
point one zero seven two three if I stop
it there but exactly what it's equal to
is pretty close but it's still the
approximation okay so depending all the
questions asking you through one of the
other
one last one can't just give you one
last one to X G equals negative okay
what are you going to do this guy any
suggestions sorry let's do the two -
okay so the first thing I'm going to do
is I want to try this problem into as
close to some of these other pieces that
I go to use number two I'm not gonna get
rid of - I'm not gonna move the to meet
our first down here I'm going to I'm
going to divide both sides by two okay
one tell me who's on the website what a
second is yes thank you mainly so that
in five minutes you all know this and
you won't need to ask again because
you'll understand it you've divided both
sides by two which please use this on
the right hand side this is also a nice
neat cubic number but no it's negative
right so if you keep smoking again alias
well then it must have been negative to
begin with and your calculator will also
tell you that the cube root of beta one
new toys life makes lets you it will
direct the occasion it is